je vais organiser un repas il va avoir
tout le monde l'attente l'oncle mes
parents la grand-mère
l'arrière-grand-mère le chien et là il
est pas bien parce qu'en fait il lui
explique que quand il a un rendez-vous
il est stressé et quand il est stressé
mais il a des gaz il lui dit écoute
t'inquiète pas chérie je sais ton
problème mais j'ai vu avec le docteur on
va prendre une capsule et à chaque fois
tes quais ça va je prends la capsule
tout va bien il arrive l'entrée il
commence à parler avec tout le monde ça
se passe bien arrive le plat là comment
ça va mal au ventre il est pas bien il a
les sueurs et il lâche une caisse énorme
oh comment il va faire et tout l'arrière
grand-mère qui regarde le chat et dort
attention Médor il continue le plat et
là du coup il a mal une deuxième caisse
j'ai attention Médor attention là il se
dit bon ben c'est bon bingo l'arrière
grand-mère elle pense que c'est le chien
je vais pouvoir me lâcher et puis
surtout j'arrive plus à me retenir
j'arrive plus à tenir de discussion je
lâche la dernière caisse alors ça c'est
la caisse de l'année ça pète ça pète
fort et elle a rien quand même regarde
le chien lui dit attention Médor je
t'avais prévenu à force il va te Chier
dessus
[Applaudissements]